Speaker 1: We wondered whether it was coming,
and it has. Donald Trump has been unbanned
from Twitter, but as of this moment, he hasn't
posted a damn thing and recently said that he
did not plan to return to Twitter even if he was
unbanned. NPR reporting on this. Elon Musk allows
Donald Trump back on Twitter. Now, what Elon
Musk did was he put out a tweet and he said,
Should I reinstate Trump to Twitter? And despite
all the claims about how much of a left wing echo
chamber Twitter is and how it's all radical left
bots, the yes reinstate votes won one on Twitter,
claiming that he was representing the will of
the people. Elon Musk then went and had Donald
Trump unbound. A quick look at Donald Trump's
Twitter account shows that his most recent tweet.
Was almost two years old. January 8th, 2021,
where he said to all of those who have asked,
I will not be going to the inauguration
on January 20th. And of course, he did not
go to the inauguration of Joe Biden. He left
Washington, D.C. before that. The one listen,
I don't know whether Trump's going to come back
to Twitter. Quite frankly, I don't care. There's
a couple interesting things here. Number one. This
decision by Elon Musk could torpedo truth, social.
Speaker 3: Trust, essential.
Speaker 1: And the reason why is as follows
Trump has said, I'm not going back on Twitter.
Truth social is the place where everything is
happening and Trump is in the middle of
trying to sell or raise money for truth
social to the tune of hundreds of millions
because truth social is going down in flames.
Even if Trump doesn't go back on Twitter, it's
harder to imagine that investors would be as
interested in truth social. Given that one of the
main reasons for its existence and creation was
that Trump was banned from Twitter. So we'll see
how that shakes out. And it would be interesting
if this decision by Musk ends up torpedoing,
torpedoing truth, social. The other thing is
that Elon Musk has, of course, seemingly gone back
on his own word. Elon Musk at the end of October
said he is not going to be unbanning any accounts
until a new content moderation council forms.
We are not aware of such a council forming.
And so big shocker, Elon Musk seems to have
gone back on his own word unbanning Donald Trump
on the say so of his own followers rather than
because of this Content Moderation Council, will
Trump ultimately be able to resist going back
on Twitter? I have no idea. Let me know what you
think. I think it's totally plausible Trump stays
off of it. I think it's also totally plausible
that if indeed his campaign content continues
to not get the attention that Trump wants it to
get, he will get desperate and try to find a way
to get more attention. And maybe going on Twitter
would be exactly that. Let me know what you think.